[Music]
from calorie council portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between burger king in the u.s and the
uk
this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk we have three drink sizes
we have a small which is 250 milliliters
this is a us small you have a regular
which is 400 milliliters this is a us
medium and we have a lodge in here
the u.s large
burger king
now in the uk we have three sizes of
fries small regular and large
here's a burger king small fry
here's a burger king medium fry
and
a burger king
large fry
so the three sizes of fries that we were
given i'm actually not sure which one is
the regular and which one is the small
because these two kind of look identical
we're going to weigh them all
we're going to start with this orange
bottom bag
80
88 grams now we're gonna weigh the
slightly darker orange bag and see which
size this is
so there's only a five gram difference
but this one
is the small
so a large rise in the uk looks like
it's around 180 grams which is double
the regular
we're actually having some concerns
about the sizes of the fries in the uk
because our measurements showed that the
lighter orange bag actually contained
more fries than the darker orange bag
however when lined up very
scientifically like this what we'll
actually see is that
the bag sizes go up in that color order
instead so i think what's happened here
is that our small was actually bigger
than our regular wow a lot of fried
drama over there in the uk as you can
see from our sizes it's pretty obvious
with the small medium and larges but of
course we're still gonna weigh them so
let's start with the small fry
yep oh
rogue fry and now the medium fry
i'm making a face i don't like that face
it's like
yeah it's pretty similar but i know how
we will solve this
but not
not that way over here burger king is in
the hot seat baby burger king's in the
hot seats
large fries
[Applause]
so i'm going to do something really
tedious and boring
2 3
4 12
13
20 21 22 35 regulars 10 kind of broken
up ones
one
two
34 and 18. but they'll have smaller ones
whoa
that's pretty cold burger king that is
pretty cold don't act like you're
surprised by this and i know what
they're gonna say they're gonna be like
well everyone who scoops it's different
okay but our scooper here and their
scooper in the uk made a similar
error
hmm
suspicious right
frygate 2020.
so this is a whopper in the uk
no it's not that's a halloumi king
is this the whopper
i forgot
burger king
so what we're going to do is weigh a
whopper and see how much a whopper
weighs in the uk
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the us
whopper
first thing i'm gonna do i'm gonna weigh
it
oh yeah
that's a whopper
oh yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
in the uk you can get burger king's
chicken fries in three sizes
a six-piece box
a
nine-piece box
or if you're really hungry
a 20-piece box
in the u.s according to the burger king
website they have three sizes of chicken
fries we went to like five burger kings
two and both of them said that they only
have one size the nine piece chicken
fries i don't know why that is and after
burger king frygate 2020
i'm gonna count these
there's nine
so what about calories well for example
a large whopper meal the whopper itself
is 627 calories
our 180 gram serving of large fries
would be 437 calories and a large coke
would be 209 calories
that brings a total of a large whopper
meal in the uk to
1273 calories
and in the u.s burger king the whopper
meal comes in at a hefty 1600 calories
that is an increase of about 378
calories a roughly 30
however there are ways to bring the
calorie count down for example if you
get the whopper without mail uh you save
yourself about 157 calories taking the
whopper down to like 503 the drink is a
major culprit if you get a sugar-free
soda like a diet coke you immediately
save yourself 510 calories so with these
minor adjustments you can get a large
whopper meal for about
933 calories
now for whatever reason the mayo in the
uk only comes to six calories so i'm not
sure what you guys are putting in your
mayo now in the uk a bacon double
cheeseburger comes in at 430 calories
and our bacon double cheeseburger in the
us only has 404 calories now this has to
be a food wars first or something in the
u.s has less calories than something in
the uk i do want to point out our bacon
double cheeseburger does not come with
mayo so i think that might be the
calorie culprit so we finally found
something that's less calorific in the
us than the uk congrats guys
error 404 mayo not found that's funny
like just put that on the screen there
like an error code
unfortunately burger king does not
disclose a full ingredients list in
either the uk or the us
here are some things you can only get at
a uk burger king so here we have the
veggie bean burger which you get these
two fried bean patties with some lettuce
some mayo and some cheese here we have
the halloumi king which is kind of
exciting
it comes with lettuce mayo onions tomato
and then these two fried pieces of
halloumi
they also offer that with bacon which
seems slightly counterproductive if
you're a vegetarian but pretty delicious
if you're not
hey siri
what is halloumi
[Music]
and sometimes also cows milk
do you want me to keep reading
[Music]
can easily be yes or grilled this
property makes it a popular meat
substitute
rennet is used to curdle the milk in
halloween production although no
acid-producing bacteria are used in its
preparation
huh
thanks
i don't want that
at the back here we have a chicken
royale with bacon which is a longer
chicken patty that's fried comes with
lettuce bacon and cheese and mayo to
round out the burgers we have the bacon
king
which is kind of like a larger version
of the bacon double cheeseburger but it
also has mayo on it and then finally
available to us right now we have the
jalapeno chicken fries which are kind of
like the standard chicken fries but with
a spicy jalapeno coating
i'm furious we don't have those that is
ridiculous how do they have the jalapeno
chicken fries on way down that is
ridiculous so on top of what i've got in
front of me there are also a lot of
exclusives that we have in the uk which
i'll read for you now
the steakhouse angus a classic cheese
melt a barbecue double melt a chili
cheese melt the roadhouse crispy chicken
sandwich a crispy bacon king
a rebel whopper mac and cheese bites
chili cheese bites apple slices a
breakfast king a range of breakfast
sandwiches including a bacon butty and a
sausage butty porridge and an oreo
fusion which is like an ice cream with
some oreos in it it has to be said that
burger king isn't the friendliest place
for vegetarians they have some kind of
vegetarian options like the halloumi
king or the rebel whopper but
unfortunately these are actually cooked
in the same oil and on the same grills
as the meat so it's not 100 vegetarian
here is everything that is exclusive to
the burger king in the united states uh
i'm just going to start
here
impossible whopper
even when we're trying to be healthy we
still managed to figure out a way to be
unhealthy there's stuff in our
impossible meat that has not been
approved in the uk yet
crispy taco here in burger king usa only
i don't know why there's tacos
at burger king i don't know who's
getting a taco at burger king that's
ridiculous
crispy
the stacker
bacon
the double stacker these things are so
heavy
this is so much now from my
understanding
what separates the stacker from the
bacon double cheeseburger is these are
quarter pound patties and also there's
some sort of stacker sauce on here
special stacker sauce
spicy crispy chicken sandwich
the barbecue bacon crispy chicken
sandwich
spicy
chicken sandwich junior
for the little guys
you can also get
an order of mozzarella sticks four with
marinara in there
uh applesauce
oh yeah breakfast oh good lord all right
so
you get pancakes and of course syrup and
of course we're gonna do a a syrup for
wouldn't it be a food wars episode
without me pouring something on
something else
you like that you like how that looks
ah yes
the chris sandwich so as you can see
what a chris sandwich is is a breakfast
sandwich where a croissant is the buns
how's it look
look good
and also
simmering mcdonald's
breakfast sandwiches they also have
breakfast biscuits also sausage egg and
cheese
uh and then last the u.s
burger king breakfast burrito
let's open it up let's take a look
inside
oh
they gotta get an egg
that's sausage oh they got potato in
here
okay
i wouldn't i would not
get this but good for them good effort
last but not least
you can also get yourself a hershey's
sunday chocolate pie oh look at that
look at that
oh man i don't want to jump into that
meaty